Hello, and welcome
to this next
session of knowledge
connections.
We're here with doctor
Maureen Tessier,
who will be presenting on
unprecedented products in
commercial real estate with
automated generation of large
knowledge graphs.
And she'll tell
you a little bit
more about herself.
Oh, thank you so
much for having
me at this conference.
I am so happy to see
that the knowledge
graph community
has grown enough
that we can have an entire
conference focused on,
creating graph structures and
taking advantage of them.
And and I'm I'm I'm
honored to be here.
And thank you all for,
joining my talk
on unprecedented
products and commercial
real estate.
I am currently
working as chief
data scientist at
Reonomy, which is a,
commercial real estate company
that builds property
intelligence,
and is located in
the United States.
Our headquarters
is in New York.
My background is,
in academia.
I well, worked,
in computational
astrophysics.
I generated and
analyzed hundreds
of terabytes of data
on cosmological
structures and
simulations of galaxies,
and you can see two images of
the simulations here.
I moved into the startup space
about six years ago.
And, one of the things that,
I was able to bring
from academia
and that I enjoy
in industry is
working in the,
where where engineering and ML
and AI meet. And,
building knowledge graphs,
provides me with
the opportunity
to do that in spades,
and that's one of the reasons
that I absolutely love
knowledge graphs.
So when you think
about commercial
real estate, this
is what people
typically think of.
They they think about
office buildings.
They think about retail.
But the way that Reonomy has
defined commercial real estate
is that it's
anything that's not
a single family residence.
So there's a huge diversity in
the data that we
have to deal with,
to cover commercial
real estate
across the US. There's,
agricultural land.
There's transit hubs.
There are, huge malls.
There's gas stations.
There's vacant land.
There are apartment
complexes.
It's it's it's
any it's anything
and everything
that that you've
that you've seen this,
not a single
family residence.
For the US,
there are a hundred
and fifty million,
lots of land that have,
been designated as either
commercial or single
family residence.
And it's a little
under a hundred
million for single
family residences,
and it's a little over fifty
million for, commercial real
estate if you're
going to cover
all of the US.
So there's a large volume of
data as well as,
some some pretty diverse data
that you have to deal with on
the on the CRE side.
So one of the motivations for
using a knowledge
graph is that
is that there's many,
many different ways that human
beings interact with
these structures.
They have constructed
the structures.
They are modifying them.
They're fixing them.
People work within
the structures
that's in they do
industrial work.
They work as, shopkeepers.
They are, they
work in offices.
But people also,
work to maintain
the buildings.
They create
the infrastructure.
They set up the Ethernet.
They do the h v HVAC to make
sure that the insides
of the building
are filling the needs
of the people
who are present there during
the days or the evenings.
These but these
structures are are also,
used in a in a completely
different way.
They're used in
as data points,
to understand how
cities behave,
how neighborhoods
are changing,
and how the market
is changing.
So so tracking
the the behavior
of commercial real
estate, I mean,
it's a huge component
of the financial
behavior of of
the United States.
And then lastly,
people own these
structures as income.
So so they collect rent,
from the people who are using
the the structures
in different ways,
and they, you know,
after they pay off
their mortgages,
that's that's their,
primary source of
income in some cases.
So there's just
a lot of different
ways that people
are interacting
with these structures.
And already,
if you've been to
to other talks
in this conference,
you're probably
thinking about,
oh, look at all of
these different
edge types that,
should be created,
to to capture these
interactions.
Another motivation
that we have
for creating a Knowledge Graph
in this space is that we have
a lot of data,
but separately,
it's not actionable.
So in order to buy
choose to buy,
sell, or or rent a a space in
a in a structure,
you need to understand
the location,
the environment
of the building.
Is this an appropriate
place for
what you're trying to to do?
Is this a neighborhood that's
gentrifying and we're seeing
some economic growth?
What does
the financial history
of this of the building
look like?
What are the tax levels?
And then also,
who are the companies
and people
that I would reach out to if I
wanted to purchase
the property
or if I wanted to to manage
the property or if I
wanted to reroof,
the the structures
on the property,
in order to so so, yeah,
so there are lots
of pieces that
need to be put
together in order
for people to to do anything
with this data.
And, because the data is not
intended to be used in the way
that we we use it,
you this this is
a really good case for,
the reorganization
that you get
from a knowledge graph.
And the third and
last motivation
for knowledge graphs,
in in in the CRE space is that
there are hidden
truths in the CRE
space. So I've
made a little bit
of a graph cartoon
that illustrates
one example of of ownership of
properties within the US.
Property ownership
is completely
legally and
completely intentionally
hidden or obfuscated
in in many,
many cases.
So if you are a person that is
famous and you
don't want people
to know that you're
buying a property,
there are there
are legal vehicles
that you can use
to kind of hide
your ownership.
But what you see more commonly
is that corporations who are
trying to maintain
some kind of
a competitive advantage when
they are buying or selling
properties will
create subsidiaries
or LLCs or DBAs
and buy properties
through, through through,
business structures that it's
not obvious where
these business
structures, connect
to the the the
the ultimate company that is
controlling, that
the behaviors.
And and,
what we've seen
from putting all
of these pieces together into
a graph is that is
that the ownership
structures can be,
six or eight hops deep.
So you can go across
six companies
or eight companies in
order to finally,
see who is who is actually
controlling and, who
owns these assets,
these commercial assets.
What does that mean
at a large scale?
What that means is
that at a high level,
we don't have
a good understanding
at all of who owns what across
the country. This is this is
something that just does not
it's it does not
exist in the world.
So the few
ownership portfolios
that that are around,
and there there are some and
there are very few.
They're expensive to create,
both in time and
in and in money
because they're done
by having humans,
research the properties and
research companies and and
manually put together
all of the pieces.
So so ownership is something
that is is highly valuable,
but is not something
that is is
not something that
that's present
and obvious in a way
that, you know,
in many European
countries, it it is.
I've been told it is.
So this is a third motivation
for us building our
Knowledge Graph.
So we have our motivation.
So what does building
the Knowledge
Graph look like?
And what do entity
based pipelines
look like?
So so the first thing that you
do is ingestion,
and you're probably getting,
flat tabular data sources.
They might be,
coming from
a relational database
database. They might be coming
from files.
And you're combining multiple
sources probably
together until
you create your graph.
In many cases, especially with
the data that we work with,
the data is incredibly messy.
There are missing values.
There are abbreviations.
There are misspellings.
There are just things that are
blatantly wrong.
There's misalignment.
So there there
are problems with
the data, and and that should
be kind of assumed
to be the the
the status quo.
If you're building
a robust pipeline,
you wanna build
against against
that expectation.
And then there's
also, context.
The data is context specific.
And and this kinda
goes back to
what I was saying before about
the data being disparate and
unconnected to other things.
And the reason that
it's unconnected
to other things
is because it's
built for one use case.
And we're trying to use it for
an entirely
different use case.
And so it's not
built for purpose.
It's built for built
for a different
purpose. The data
is mixed because
you have rows of
data where you
have information on multiple
different entity types.
So the the information about
the entities can
be mixed within
both columns and rows.
And then you
should expect that
you will get duplicates,
inter source,
so within the sources of data
that you're ingesting,
but also inter
source duplication,
if you are ingesting multiple
sources that kind
of cover the same
space. And that's
something that
you absolutely
would want to do
if you are looking to improve
the overall quality
of data that
you're putting
into your graph.
If you have we have multiple
data sources for companies.
We have multiple data sources
for properties,
and we have we do that very
intentionally.
And at duplicate
coverage, we can combine them
to to get
an overall improvement
in the in the data quality,
for for each area. Okay.
So the next step
is standardization
and cleaning. And
there are very
good reasons to put this very
early in the pipeline
when you're
doing when you're doing graph
construction. And primarily,
this is because
you're going to
be taking these
data sources and
shredding them
into two pieces.
And in some cases,
you'll be multithreading.
So so you might
have attributes
that could go to
multiple entities
depending on the definition of
your ontology and how you've,
how you've constructed it and
how dense your your graph is.
So doing the standardization,
doing the data cleaning very
early before you get
into the messiness
of the graph and you're trying
to use the values that you've
pulled from the data,
as well as
the context given to
you by the structure
of the data
in order to do
resolution is is
very important. Right?
If you don't do it,
you're handicapping your your
resolution efforts. Okay.
And next,
we get into this
green section.
This green section
is where you
see a difference in the two
pipeline options that I'm that
I'm presenting today.
So one option is that you you
take your stand
your your tabular,
flat, clean,
standardized data,
and you create
graph structures
immediately, and you throw it
into potentially,
you throw it into
a graph database
right away.
And there are there are
ramifications for doing this.
So I'm gonna talk about I'm
gonna go into
more detail about
both of both of
these different
cases and talk about
the ramifications
for throwing
something in early
and then performing resolution
or taking
an alternative approach
and doing resolution and edge
creation and and then throwing
the components into
a graph database.
They're they're a little bit
different faces of
the same coin,
but they actually have pretty
profound effects on the volume
of data that you
process and how
you process it and even some,
limitations. It sets some
limitations potentially
on the algorithms
that you want to do
to do resolution.
But at the end of
this green phase,
you will have
a knowledge graph
where where, you know,
you have resolved entities.
So you have each
entity is unique.
You have multiple different
entity types.
You have a ton of
different edge types.
And, potentially,
you have a beautiful knowledge
graph to use. But knowledge
graphs in and of themselves,
they're they're not
products. Right?
They're just it's
just a data store.
It's just a thrilling paradigm
shift in storing data.
So so there are
additional steps.
Right? One is extraction,
and creation of
of data packages
for products. So
this is you're
extracting information that is
a subset of
the information that
you contain within the graph,
and it's much more opinionated
and built for purpose.
And then the last piece is is
delivery of,
of the data that
you've extracted
for the graph, and you want to
be able to deliver
that in a performant
and and compatible way.
There are some specific cases
where you might be able to get
away with,
having a graph be your primary
data store and have your your
your potentially, like,
a UI layer or your API layer
directly interact
with the graph.
But in a lot of cases,
people are going to be asking
for traversal that
you are going
to cause, performance
problems because,
graph structures
notoriously have,
have there's they're they get
pretty slow pretty
quickly when
you're doing a lot
of traversal.
And so depending
on what you're
trying to build
into your product,
it's probably not a good idea
to have the graph
directly support
your product. You wanna have
intermediate layers
where you're
extracting the data,
and then you're
adding that data
into a different type of
infrastructure
in order to have
a really high
quality performant
product to deliver
to your clients.
Okay. So this seems pretty
complete and end to end,
but there's something that is
glaringly missing,
and that is and that
is your ontology.
And and the ontology,
as as you all know,
because I know
that that's been
addressed multiple times in
the in the conference is,
is is your is your
building plan.
Right? It's it's
like a building
plan for a house.
It defines all of the things
that you need.
These are all of
the entities that cover this
this domain space,
this industry.
These are all of
the edge types.
These are the things that we
would want for attributes as
opposed to entities,
etcetera.
So, your your ontology is I
advise actually,
defining the ontology
first and
using it to inform different
phases of the pipeline.
And and the reason that I've
introduced it
second is because
the context that you've gotten
from our our
short conversation
about the pipeline is is going
to show you how,
we use the ontology to inform
what we're doing at these
different phases.
So one of the things
that the ontology
is is great at is,
giving you confidence that you
have good coverage
from the data
that you're ingesting
across the space.
And this is this
is very important
because if you
are not covering
your entire ontology, then,
that there there's
a chance that
you're going to,
not just miss things
from your graph,
but also come up
with erroneous
conclusions. So
you're going to
get things wrong.
It depends a little bit on it
depends a lot on
the on the space
that you're using
and the products
that you're building,
but but that's the risk.
The ontology also helps with
the resolution in that if you
have a have a plan,
a a a structural
plan for the types
of entities that
you want to see
and the attributes
on those entities,
then you can make
sure that when
you're doing
the standardization
and you're doing
the cleaning,
that you're covering all of
those things in
order to set you
up for success
when you're doing
resolution.
The ontology also helps inform
the graph structures because
once you're at
the point in your
pipeline where you have this
beautiful knowledge graph,
you want to be
able to evaluate
it in order to
understand whether
you're you're really getting
things right. Are you under
resolving your entities?
Are you over resolving them?
Do you have is do
you have the right
volume of each entity type?
Do you have the right do you
have good coverage of all of
your different edge types?
And that's something that you
can you you can
reference the ontology
in order to give you a better
understanding of,
whether your graph is looks
the way that it needs to.
And then lastly,
the ontology is,
something that's very valuable
in supporting product.
And this is where it shows up
in the pipeline,
but but, again,
you want your
ontology early and
you want it to
inform the different
phases of the pipeline.
And this is one
of those phases
where you do want
to use the ontology
to work with,
both the to kind of
form a a a document
layer that pulls the product
people and
the technical people
together. And,
if you've done it
successfully,
then the extraction
and the packaging
of the data from your graph,
will work very,
very well for supporting
the product.
And if you haven't done that
successfully, then then you'll
have to make
some modifications
to your ontology
and and go back
and look at some of your edge
types and some of the entities
that you're doing
resolution on
and and and change
the way that
you're processing data. Okay.
So let's dig into these green
sections a little bit more.
So for for the for the top
situation where you are,
exploding your
data and you are,
throwing things into,
graph structures and a graph
database potentially, early,
you will be,
treating the data
in a a maximalistic
way. And what I mean
by maximalistic
is that you are exploding your
your data. You're
taking if you
have a tabular
data set and you
take the rows
within that tabular
data set and you
use the implicit
information that
they're all all
of these things
are on the same
row and you explode
those into edges,
you are increasing the volume
of the data that you have to
compute over.
So you're doing
and, potentially,
you're doing maximal
edge creation
where maybe you don't have any
attributes on
your entities and
everything you're treating
everything as an entity,
and so every cell within,
the tables that
you're probably
ingesting, will be
will be exploded.
So so you potentially,
you're exploding
your data a a great
deal depending on how you've
defined your ontology.
You inter source
edge creation,
there that that's
something that
also is typically done first
when you are,
exploding exploding
the data and
creating the graph components
and putting them
into the graph
before you try to
do resolution.
And, there are simple
ways to do that.
Right? It it's
people have been
doing that using rules and
similarity metrics
for for quite
some time now. There are more
sophisticated ways.
The example that
I have on this
slide where we have Jenny and
she has the number eight six
seven five three zero nine is
probably the most simple case
that that you can look at.
So there's there's
a phone number.
It's formatted in
the same way.
It's the same phone number.
The name is the same.
There's some
attribute information
that's different,
but there's high
enough confidence
that we can collapse the edges
and the entities
into something
that looks like a structure
that's at the bottom
of the slide.
And that's why I also cause
the this option
for constructing
your pipeline
destructive because
you're doing entity resolution
through destroying edges and
destroying vertices. Right?
So your resolution is
edge contraction.
There are lots of models that
you can use, for
for to do this.
Right? There's hyper
node creation.
There's path finding.
There's clustering.
There's graph CNNs.
There's deep walks,
and there have been,
several talks and
I think a few
more to come on
a lot of these,
techniques. The the thing that
I that I wanna
emphasize here,
because it's something to be
aware of before you
create the situation
for yourself is that you are
looking at something that's
potentially traversal
heavy. Right?
So depending on the complexity
of the entity that
you're trying
to resolve on, you might not
have all of the attributes on
the entity. You
might not have,
you know, all of the,
the neighboring entities that
you're going to
use to collapse
your your the entity
that you're
focused on resolving.
You might not have those next
to each of these.
So you might end
up in a situation
where you're doing a lot of
traversal across the graph.
And, even if you're
doing extraction,
you you still have to do that
traversal step.
So you're creating a situation
for yourself where,
you're increasing
the the computational
time that the this
step in your
pipeline will take to run.
The other option,
I call minimalistic
and constructive.
And the reason that I call it
minimalistic is
that it it aims
to keep the data as compressed
as possible before
it's delivered
to the app. And
you you're only
creating the entities that you
know that you are
going to need.
So you do entity
creation first.
You have a model
per entity, type.
You could also
have a model per
edge type, but
you might not you
don't necessarily need that if
the edges are explicit
or implicit,
within your data sources.
And so the way
that you go about
the the entity
create the entity
creation in this case, right,
is that you have two datasets
and you maybe you have person
information in dataset one and
person information in dataset
in dataset two,
and you want to
see if the person
information in
these rows actually
belongs to the same entities.
So you group the information
from these records together
using adaptive blocking,
which is just
a fast high recall
step in order to find the most
likely candidates
for resolution.
And then you run your high
accuracy model,
which could be a machine
learning model,
it could be AI,
or it could be
a probabilistic model.
And, if you're
constructing a knowledge
graph, you might
have you might
have all of the above.
You might have used every
technique that
that you've seen
on the on the slide so far,
depending on depending on what
your data looks like. Right?
So you so you
should be tailoring
the technique. It should be
based on what's required by
the by the data,
by the values,
and and potentially
by the graph
structures.
Adaptive the cons,
for for using the this this
approach is is that adaptive
blocking in particular creates
a lot of skew in
in the pipeline,
which can slow your
pipelines down.
And then because you're being
minimalistic, there could be
things that you
did not anticipate
or understand about the data,
and and so you
could be missing
graph components
because of that.
Right. And then the edges in
this case are are
created after
the entities, and they're
explicitly defined
potentially,
they're explicitly
or implicitly
defined in the source
data, right,
through, through,
primary and secondary keys or
just by the presence of things
on the same row.
And you can use the adaptive
the same adaptive blocking
techniques with ML, AI,
probabilistic models.
And our and
the question is just
different. It's not,
are these things
this are these
pieces of information,
do they belong to
the same thing?
It's not that.
It's the is this
thing connected
to this thing?
Okay. So this is just a little
bit of an overview about some
of the things that I've talked
about for two
different approaches,
two different
pipeline approaches,
and how that has
ramifications on,
some of the model choices that
you might make.
And, oh,
and I forgot to talk about
flexibility and
attribute choice.
For so so for for
the for the first
case, you probably want to
skew towards
creating more more
entities. Right?
Whereas in the second case,
you might want to skew towards
creating less
entities in order
to keep the graph more compact
and the the volume
of data going
through your
pipeline, smaller.
And an example of where you
would do this is like
a phone number.
So is a is a phone
number really
valuable to the product
as an entity,
or is it right?
And is it valuable
to the model?
Is it needed by the technique
that you're using to
do the resolution?
Or is it really valuable
as an attribute
that you use to
create a connection?
And the edge that's important
is how the person
is related to
a company, not
that a person is
related to a phone number and
a phone number is
related to a company.
So it's important to really
think about your
edge types and
what's needed for
the product,
as I mentioned before. Okay.
So at Reonomy, we've thought
about all of these
things, and we have,
pretty extensive,
to say the least,
pipelines with
a lot of models.
And so what what
we've ended up
with at this point,
and and work is
still ongoing,
is we have over
fifty million,
resolved property entities.
We have over a hundred million
resolved company entities.
We have over sixty
five million
resolved people
that are related
to the companies
and the properties
within the Reonomy Graph.
So any people that
aren't involved
in the commercial
real estate space,
we don't care about them.
They're not included.
And then and then
we have, over,
thirty billion
entity attributes,
hanging off of these entities
in our graph.
So so it's it's
it's quite a bit
of information, and,
we found it to be
very powerful.
So, one of the ways that it's
displayed in our
product is this
property centric
view where for
each property node,
we have a page,
about that property.
So it has some attributes like
the address, structural
information.
There's a model
that runs that,
defines whether
the property is
likely to sell in
the next several
months. You have transactional
information attached
to the property.
And then we also,
do have information
that it came
ultimately from
graph traversal.
Right? So we have
a tenant list that,
where you where
we went from our
property entity to
the company entities,
that with the edge
types of tenants.
And then and then we also used
the structure,
the ownership structure,
to create an ownership tree
where we have
contact information
that we display in the app,
for companies and
people as you
as you go up that
tree away from
your prop your
property entities.
But the true power
of knowledge
graphs is in their
flexibility.
And this is where it starts to
get really I mean,
it's exciting so far.
But this is where it starts to
get really exciting.
So so I just
showed you part of
our product that
has a property
centric view,
and we're looking
at the rest of the world,
captured by our graph,
from the perspective
of the property.
And, again,
this is just this
is just a this
is a cartoon.
This is just kind
of like the ownership
cartoon of of,
one case in our in
our in our graph.
But when you when
you have a graph,
you can change perspectives.
And what this means is that we
can take the perspective
of a company
or a person and
look at the world
of commercial real estate and
specifically look
at ownership.
And what this means is that
because of our
knowledge graph,
we can build
something that has
never been done before.
It does not it it didn't exist
before we did this.
And and that is
create ownership
portfolios covering every
commercial property
across the United
States. So what does
that look like?
Well, this is what
it looks like
in the beta product
that we have
available to,
some of our users
currently. This is
a a company page.
So this is from the company
perspective of Spirit
Realty Capital.
You can see that
there are over
a thousand properties in their
portfolio. You can
look at the history
of the portfolio.
You can look at
the valuation.
If you you have
some information
about the employees,
about the company,
you have a breakdown
of the asset
types for the properties.
And then if you
wanted to go and
look at
the individual property
centric views,
you could navigate
to do that by clicking on this
list of properties
at the bottom.
I love the the map here.
You can see that they cover
the entire United
States as well.
And then and then, of course,
we can do it we
do it for people
as well. So so this is a this
is a property owner
in in Cleveland.
And you can see
from his property
breakdown, what he specializes
in is taking vacant land and
building small
multifamily homes,
out of them.
So in in summary,
right, I've I've,
described the motivation for
using knowledge graphs.
It's it's much
more than having
disparate data.
It's also capturing
the complexity
of human interaction
with the other
components in the graph.
It is discovering
hidden truths,
and then it's taking advantage
of the product
flexibility that
you can get from
a a data store
that is less opinionated and
more true to
the real world than
our the relational databases
that we have all
been using for
such a long time.
The I've talked a little bit
about how the knowledge graph
sits within
a production pipeline
and the choices
that the things
that you have to
think about and
the choices that
you have to make,
for designing and
creating those
production pipelines.
And how those
choices will affect
your engineering performance,
your ease of
implementation for
different types of models,
and and potentially
even affect
your ontology a little bit.
And then shown that
the flexibility
of a knowledge graph makes it
possible to create
products that
have not existed
before in the world.
And that's it. Thank
you so much for,
for joining my talk.
Happy to have all
of you there.
Thank you, Maureen.
This was a fabulous,
succinct,
powerful overview of
the entire process,
and it's really
nice to get that
from an industry perspective
where we're thinking about
production performance
and things
like that. So
really appreciate
this talk. We have a couple of
questions and a couple
of minutes left,
so I'm going to read
these quickly.
First one is from
Benjamin Grossoff.
What size ontologies are you
working with currently?
Not instance,
not actual data,
but just the size
of the ontology
in terms of entity classes,
edge relation types,
that kind of thing.
So I,
we consider our
ontology a little
bit proprietary
because there's
a lot of nuance
in the CRE space
and there's a lot of nuance in
the in the business space.
So I'm not like,
we don't typically
share, like,
numbers or create
a list of something,
which is why I showed
a cartoon of of,
like, what what
the ownership,
part of the graph
would look like.
So I don't know that I can go
into a lot of detail there.
Is there such
a thing as, like,
a range of what's
sort of typical
without, you know,
asking about
proprietary just as,
like, a ballpark
for someone who
has no idea?
I I think that
the the ontology
really is really
dependent on,
whether you're
trying to capture
an entire industry or whether
you're trying to capture maybe
a subset of an industry.
So if you're if
you're building
an ontology, for example,
one that I've heard,
several times now is,
building an ontology
for for medicine,
you would probably
start with,
like, a subset of
of of medicine
and look at interactions and
look at adverse events.
And and,
so your your ontology could be
much smaller than
something that
that is trying to
capture the entire
world of, I don't know,
medical knowledge and,
instruments as
well as medicines
and met you know,
different techniques
and hospitals
and all and all of that.
So it's,
the ontology
should be designed
for should be
designed to cover
the the the product and all
the product use cases.
And and by that,
I don't mean that it should be
restrictive.
There's definitely,
kind of,
creativity that you wanna take
advantage of.
And and there's an element of
discovery in in in creating
these knowledge graphs.
So you you definitely can
anticipate
everything that that
you would wanna capture.
So it's better more more is
better than less.
And, but, yeah,
it's really hard.
So so, you know, at
a previous position,
I I we were we
built a knowledge
graph and, one of the things
that we're looking
at was bad actors,
and we're looking at
money laundering.
And, you can
identify bad actors
just by having,
person entities
and by having,
company entities.
Like and that's
and that's it.
And it's and it's
the structures
of the graph
fragments that you
get that allow
you to identify,
oh, this person's
a money launderer.
Right. It's it's
almost because
you bring in
the interpretative context.
Right? So if, you know,
you have someone
who is associated
with Bernie Madoff's
company, like,
you know, this is
not a good thing.
Sure. Or or someone that's
associated with, many,
many different companies in or
and has not just
associated, but,
like, created many,
many different
companies in a short
amount of time.
That's something
that you don't
typically see with
someone who's
trying to build a business.
That's something that you see
with somebody who is trying to
do bad things. And,
and especially if
they're in a cluster
with a a handful
of other people,
that are that are also doing
the same behavior,
it's it's so different than
the normal human behavior that
that you see that
it just really
leaps out at you.
So it's the pattern
really that
is exposed. So I think there's
time maybe for one
last question.
If this isn't proprietary,
what was your
very first follow
the money business use case,
if that's also
clear? Yeah. Yeah.
So so a really I mean,
a really big one was,
a really big one
was these owner
portfolios. And, you know,
we've been working on creating
the owner portfolios for for
over a year, for about a for
about a year and a half.
And, but but Reonomy
has had resolved,
property entities
for for quite
some time, many,
many years now.
And, so I think that
the the creation
of graph structures
is motivated
even before we
decided to go after,
owner portfolios.
The the motivation of graph
usage was motivated
by the complexity
and the ownership structures
that we see in in the US.